so unfortunately it's become very toxic
now to talk about what's going on with
russia and ukraine and there's almost no
assertion that can be made
without someone popping up out of the
woodwork and saying no no no no
that's uh a tanky talking point or
that's an imperialist talking point or
whatever even relatively
uncontroversial
statements like putin likes to play
games with his aggression it's like you
know who could possibly deny something
like that uh but someone is lying and
there is some truth and i don't think we
really know it and unfortunately what
has become very toxic about discussing
the russia ukraine story
is that
uh
any claim
triggers someone into saying you are
playing a role for x y or z
um side or perspective or enclave or
whatever the case may be
this gets us to the latest news which is
well on the one hand we were told
that vladimir putin and russia were
pulling troops back from the ukrainian
border
that would be a great thing if it were
true making it less likely that there is
going to be an invasion unfortunately
nato and the us and ukraine and others
say not only is russia not pulling back
they seem to actually be building up
troops even further now someone is lying
both can't be true um and i guess
theoretically the way that
you you could have
sort of some technical truth to both
would be there has been some pullback in
one area near the ukrainian border
with a buildup elsewhere and then both
sort of may be true but the spirit of it
of course is like overall is russia
moving towards ukraine or away from it
there's a new reuters report which says
west warns military buildup near ukraine
growing not shrinking that's very direct
and very clear estonia says russia
likely to launch a limited attack russia
releases video showing tanks leaving
crimea ukraine defense ministry hack
worst of its kind says government and
there's a question as to whether russia
is responsible for that hack um there's
a growing russian military presence at
ukraine's borders western countries
warned on wednesday as estonia said
battle groups were moving ahead of a
likely attack to occupy key terrain
contradicts contradicting moscow's
insistence of a pullback more armored
vehicles helicopters and a field
hospital have been spotted
britain's defense intelligence chief
said in rare public comments up to 7 000
more troops have moved to the border in
recent days including some arriving on
wednesday a senior official in biden's
administration said without providing
evidence so there are people who will
say we can't trust biden we can't trust
nato anything they say simply cannot be
believed
they're just straight up lying obviously
putin is
pulling back from ukraine
it doesn't seem obvious and uh i think
the other part of this situation that's
gotten difficult and this is just it's
if i sound bummed out it's because i am
that this has now become
almost like a uh it's sort of like a
venezuela type situation for some on the
revolutionary left
where there's this wing of the left that
ends up i mean the right is totally gone
cuckoo i'm not even addressing them
right now but there's this wing of the
left that ends up
in their desire to always oppose
american imperialism and american
intelligence
they will end up
supporting
um and defaulting to believing
authoritarian strong men around the
world and we saw this with venezuela
where if you say hey you know
the stated populist ideals of
chavez and now maduro
are just window dressing for
authoritarianism
and the pillaging of the country's
resources for the gain of the elites and
honor if you say that you're
wow you're you're an american
imperialist no what did i say about
wanting the u.s involved in any way i
said nothing about that
but that's how you're branded and
unfortunately if you say hey you know
putin's intentions may not be all on the
up and up here uh similar allegations
fly and unfortunately or
i don't i don't even know if it's a
question of fortune but
speaking realistically we don't really
know vladimir putin's intentions here
his intention may be to invade ukraine
his intention may be not to invade
ukraine but to goad the west into doing
something which will give him a leg up
in negotiating a
position in the future putin's intention
may be to do this to rattle western
stock markets which it has been doing
like if that were putin's goal it has
succeeded i do not think we really know
and what we do know from history is it's
unclear why anyone would believe putin
absent real solid evidence the video of
tanks moving in one direction doesn't
really tell us definitively what is
going on that video could be could be
anything could have been filmed anytime
uh it quite literally is of no value
whatsoever and uh we know that trump
believed putin right like when putin
told trump we didn't hack anybody trump
immediately immediately came out and
said listen i asked him did you hack us
and he was very strong in his denial and
i believe him okay well so we know trump
believed putin most people don't believe
putin unless they have independently
verified the things that vladimir putin
is saying so that's where we are
um one last thing from dw
nato fears russia is seeking pretext to
attack ukraine that's another idea which
is what putin is doing
is to
cause ukraine to do something which will
then justify the invasion and that's why
we see the back and forth so we're not
going to know maybe for another day
maybe for another week we don't know but
anybody telling you
this is the ultimate and definitive
truth on what putin intends to do be
skeptical of that be skeptical of that
because we don't know
and anybody
telling you i mean it's a very trumpian
thing which we'll sometimes hear from
those on the revolutionary left you say
i you can only tr i know the real thing
anything else you're hearing can't be
trusted this is the one definitive
explanation and analysis be skeptical of
that
uh you you will do you will do well to
remain skeptical of of those such uh
claims
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video